تفرقهما السياسه لكن تجمعهما المصالح
الاقتصاديه الاتحاد الاوروبي والصين
يحاولان ايجاد طريق سالكه للشراكه
المستقبليه في غابه دوليه تحكمها الصراعات
والتطاحنات العلاقات الاقتصاديه بين بيكين
وبروكسل وثيقه رغم نمو تيار داخل الاتحاد
يدعو الى تقليل التعامل معها فقبل حوالي
سنتين تمكنت الصين من تبوء مكانه الشريك
التجاري العالمي الاول للمنطقه الاوروبيه
خلفا للولايات المتحده
حاملا ملفات السياسه والاقتصاد حل الرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون بالصين الى جانب
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسولا فوندير
لاين التي استبقت رحلتها بخطاب اكدت فيه
ان على اوروبا اللجوء الى ادوات دفاعيه
جديده في علاقتها مع التنين الاسيوي وما
تقصده هو وقف تصدير التكنولوجيا الحساسه
الى الصين وتقليل الاعتماد على الاستيراد
منها ما اعتبره السفير الصيني لدى بروكسل
انتهاكا لقواعد التجاره الدوليه
الرئيس الفرنسي ومن خلال هذه الزياره يسعى
للاستمرار بالدفع باتجاه ولوج افضل الى
السوق الصينيه كما انه لا ينسى السياسه
والحرب في اوكرانيا فحسب ماكرون بكين
يمكنها ان تؤثر في صنع السلام بسبب قربها
من موسكو
لقد اثرت الحرب التي قادتها روسيا في
اوكرانيا بشكل عميق على النظام الدولي
الذي عرفناه منذ عام 19
هذه الحرب انتهكت العديد من مبادئ ميثاق
الامم المتحده والتي يجب علينا الدفاع
عنها بحزم لذا يمكن للصين على وجه التحديد
بسبب علاقاتها الوثيقه مع روسيا ان تلعب
دورا رئيسيا زياره ماكرون
فيه الصراع بين الولايات المتحده والصين
سواء في شان ما تراه واشنطن مسانده صينيه
لروسيا في حرب اوكرانيا او الخلاف بشان
تايوان
تصعد اجراءاتها الاقتصاديه والتجاريه
اتجاه بيكن وتضغط على حلفائها الاوروبيين
للحد من علاقاتهم التجاريه والاقتصاديه مع
الصين لكن منطق المصالح يجعل هذه العلاقه
اقتصاديه اولا واخيرا
بلال الوجداني العربيه